welcome back to episode 5 of my beginner
C++ series we are now going to take
everything we learned so far and make a
little program with some actual logic
that does an actual thing in what we're
gonna make is an adder it's it's just
gonna be a program that runs on a loop
as long as the user wants to continue
and either adds subtracts multiplies or
divides two numbers now if you can think
of how to how to do this on your own I
encourage you to pause it right here and
attempt to build this adder yourself
otherwise if you don't want to give it a
go on your own and wanted to see how
it's done let's jump into it so first of
all I'm gonna delete all this stuff and
I'll put 5 here and adder or more like a
calculator so doing these little
programs where you have to control flow
or great practice from you're a beginner
and if you if you go to school or boot
camp this is some of the first lab stuff
they'll have you do is things like this
ok I'm gonna keep this as running
variable and I'm gonna leave that true
the number of loops to run we're gonna
get rid of X we're not going to use that
but we do need a flag for whether the
user wants to do and add and multiply or
divide or plus minus multiply or divide
and we're gonna do a while loop and
we're going to do this while is running
now sometimes you'll see while is
running equals equals true that might be
a little clearer but it's it ends up
just checking what this evaluates to so
since this is a boolean we can leave it
just by itself because it's by itself it
evaluates to true and when it's false it
evaluates to false so it's good enough
just like this but you'll see it both
ways it is a little clearer when you
like this or sometimes you'll say the
while not false which is essentially the
exact same thing so just want to point
that out because that is something you
do see so Wow it's running we're going
to keep taking calculations basically so
at the very end we're going to want to
check whether the one the user wants to
continue or not so let's go ahead and
put that in and we're going to just be
using the console in and out for this so
we won't need any other headers other
than the plain old iostream so we'll put
at the very end do another calculation
and we'll put in parentheses here
yes slash a y /n representing that we
want to take those and then right here
we'll take a see it and make we kind of
need a something to hold the value so
we'll just do it care called I'll just
call it answer and we'll set it equal to
zero to start out that way it doesn't
have a random value and we're gonna see
in answer then we will say if answer
equals equals y so if they end up
pressing Y and then enter we'll just say
continue which basically breaks to the
next loop otherwise if they don't press
Y I'll do an else and this else will be
oh there's that again is running equals
false so this little chunk here is gonna
ask the user if they want to do another
calculation perhaps this variable in
case we need it we could also just do
this up here so it doesn't always read
eclair
but I'm gonna do it here just to keep it
encapsulated in place that's used and
we're going to check if they pressed
just the Y character and continue and if
it's anything else so the yes knows a
little I mean we could make it a little
more careful about what it takes in and
actually check for a y Capital y etc but
we'll just put Y to do another sometimes
making these console programs clear take
some careful analysis but that should
take care of it there and there we go so
now if we just run that we will get well
let me go ahead and uh g plus plus
main.cpp runs do another calculation yes
yes yes as long as we're hitting y it's
gonna it's gonna keep going as soon as
we hit something else it'll exit so
there we go that's how we keep our while
while loop running in this particular
instance now we want to have the logic
here to do our actual calculation thing
first thing we need to know is do they
want to do plus minus or divide so we'll
take in that so first here we will
declare let's we need some kind of
variable to do an if-else on or switch
on you know I haven't showed you switch
yet so I'm gonna show you switch switch
switches are very much like an if-else
but they're basically a big if-else that
works off of only a single variable and
they're a little bit more efficient than
an if-else so if you don't have a really
complicated logic and you just want to
do potentially multiple different things
um depending on what one variable is a
switch statement is going to be better
so we'll use a switch and maybe we'll
use some a else's too so we'll declare
and
for a flag and we'll call this will just
call it choice for now pretty plain name
and we'll start it out with a zero and
we'll ask the user and Wade will give
them a little little feedback here to
press one for and two for subtract and
three for multiply or for divide and you
can make this however you want this is
just kind of a way to for me to get it
done as you see your see out maybe it
won't look good and you can carefully
make your syntax better and clearer if
you need to and then we'll just do a CN
on this choice so anytime you do this CN
and bring in a variable you're waiting
for user prompt on that variable and
then we'll do a switch on our choice and
this is the syntax of a switch you start
out with switch variable you want to
switch on a set of brackets to go into
the scope and then you start doing cases
and you do case one so we want to do
different things for one two and three
so we're gonna have cases one two and
three and at the end of every case you
do need a break or it keeps going down
it doesn't a short-circuit like if else
does if you don't break it'll keep
checking all the it'll keep going
so I'm just gonna initially build these
cases and then at the end you want a
default for if it hits none of them and
we'll just say
if they if they end up going to the
default we'll say not a valid choice put
on these other ones we want to start
doing our character calculation and in
these cases you can you can just start
doing your code or you can also enter a
scope if you're declaring variables in
your case
you do need to enter scope that's not
absolutely necessary we are going to
enter a scope because we're going to
well I guess we don't necessarily need
to but we do need to take in some
numbers to add subtract multiply or
multiply or divide so up here we're
going to have we'll just use these
floats and we'll do first number and
second number and we're going to start
these out as 0 so I'll do an equals 0
equals 0 now we could also keep these
within the scope of gist yeah of just
this two and that way every time the
loop restarts they reset to 0 so
actually this might be a little better
and I'm not doing them static because I
do want them to read a Claire just to
reset their values I did them as static
they would stick as the number they were
before which might ask us so it would be
what we want especially for choice but
in this case it's not going to matter a
whole lot either way so in case one if
they chose add so we'll do a another
prompt here that says enter first number
to add and then we'll see end first
number and then we'll do a see out to
prompt enter second number to add and
we'll do a cien second number and
that'll prompt them for
what we need and I'm gonna clean this up
a little bit and just to add numbers so
that way they reiterates what they chose
and that way I can get rid of this I'm
gonna be reusing some of this code and
then so once those are prompted in no
just spit out the result the result of
first number put a plus symbol to know
what we're doing second number and
equals here and then we'll add them
together and then we'll do a newline so
right within the C out here it's gonna
do the calculation on the fly now we
could declare another variable do the
calculation ahead of time and then spit
out that new one but this works fine too
so there we go so if we go ahead and run
this we can test that it actually does
the at least the add portion and what
doesn't it like here oh I forgot to put
more little alligators things more less
than symbols okay and now we're running
and we do get our prompt way down here
in the corner here press 1 for add to
track 3 for multiply for right so we'll
go ahead and press our 1 and enter and
tells us add numbers and your first
number how about five point five and six
point two and there tells us our result
maybe I'll make it a little more
explicit and even say results here
and there we go we have a basic adder
that we can run in a loop if we want to
do another we press yes if we do it
again
I hit for it's gonna do nothing because
it's gonna go to this case that we
haven't built yet but if you didn't go
ahead at the very beginning and do this
all on your own now would be a great
chance to pause the video and attempt to
build these other three cases on your
own now that you see how the adder is
done that would be a great little
getting started experiment for you okay
there we go so let's build the next once
here's the answer I'm going to go ahead
and just do some copy paste to make this
quick so this is no longer add it is
subtract and we're going to change this
so that tells user it says - and of
course this over here needs to be - so
there we go that would take care of the
subtract and now we want to do the
multiply and just update these to
represent what we're doing and now we
want to do the divide last now one thing
that's pretty cool is I used to like to
do when I was a pretty new coder as I
liked it I used to like to build these
four different calculations I had for
whatever a project I I was doing and
there's more tricks you can do than just
always prompt like you can pull in from
a file which I might bet start showing
starting next episode so we can get even
more advanced I could show you how to
work with other files and not have to
manually type things in let's see in all
the time
okay well do divide numbers divide now
divide is a little trickier because
dividing by 0 results in infinite and
will often crash or program so let's go
ahead and run this I'm going to do it
clear
and compile and now we will run it and
we're gonna do our divide because I
think the rest are pretty well built and
should work just fine but I want to show
you what happens when you divide by zero
into first number and I will do 5.5
second number if we put zero here well
this particular compiler knows how to
handle it and says infinity but some
older compilers do not know how to
handle this and they won't give you a
result they will just crash so it would
be a really good idea to make sure this
second number wasn't never zero so what
we could do here is we could do a little
control flow say while second number
it's not equal or while it equals equals
zero and we'll do this sort of thing you
know what let's actually use a do-while
because we definitely want to do it once
no matter what so we can get the updated
number but if it's zero we want to loop
and do it again yeah and we'll put a
little notification here if it is zero
we also want to say can't divide by zero
try again wait a second number and I'll
put a whole new line there and I guess
it might be better to have this in here
too so every time it loops it puts the
prompt in front of it so there we go
that'll make sure we don't get a zero in
that slot so let's go ahead and run that
exit our program there recompile
we'll test our divine in her first
number second number of zeros make sure
yeah it says can divide by zero try
again one keep so it's just not going to
allow it and there we go
now something I will warn you of as a
final thing as I in this video is this
is a float right and a floating-point
number this compiler hands what handles
this particular thing fine like it
doesn't affinity I guess it's a little
more advanced or updated but a lot of
them a lot of floats even if you set
them to exactly zero and then compare
them to zero it will end up being false
and the reason that is is because they
end up being a value that looks like
let's see something like this and that's
not exactly zero so on some compilers
this will will never work correctly with
the flow so you'd want it to be an
integer so a little bit of a more
careful way to handle this would be to
cast this as an integer as you check it
mmm but that might not actually actually
that's gonna cause problems too I guess
I'll just say you might have to think of
a better solution such as putting a
limit on it like something like if it's
less than it's less than that and ends
up being greater than and just put it
within a boundary like this and I think
so this might be a better way of
checking for if a flow to zero if it's
less than that tiniest wolf one it could
be and greater than be the negative of
that that way it's like a clamp to 0
basically
so that should essentially work the same
and of course we would have dater one
down here but that's just something to
know about floats it's something I've
been stuck on before and the life of me
couldn't see the bug because I was like
it's a direct comparison it can't be
wrong and it ended up being the source
of my problem so there you know there
you go
so we'll give that a test hopefully
enter zero with our new yep still
detects correctly okay and two we can
keep our loop going repressing why and
just keep doing calculations this might
mean something like this might be good
for doing something like an interest
calculator for different interest rates
where you could punch in the interest
rate the yearly amount run your
calculation things like that well I hope
you enjoyed this episode I hope you
learned a lot it's been really fun
making these so far and teaching the
world a little about about coding so I
will see you in the next episode I'm
going to scroll through this one last
time
in case someone wants to see it all or I
guess I could make it a little tinier
and fit it all on the screen at once
there we go that's it alright see you in
the next episode have a good day keep on
coding